here's something that is kind of simple
i think um it's a video
taken by a mom who's was very proud to
take this video and put it online for
everyone to see
uh she
is letting her daughter know that um
that that she the daughter will soon be
able to be vaccinated
and uh this is supposed to be a
heartwarming video based on the
young girl's reaction but i have a
i feel a little bit differently about it
let's let's watch this
this is my daughter hi
she's nine
we're about to blind react to something
okay what does that say
hold on dear
what does it say
that the coven vaccine for kids is
so next week should be
clear for kids to 5 to 11.
what does that mean for you i can
go with my friends yeah
i can finally you know go outside
go to stores
i'm excited
i'm excited
i thought i was gonna be like in a
couple months no probably it's next week
i love you mom
she's white you need to get vaccinated
okay
no she's why you need to be in prison
you
monster
this is another another of those tough
ones i almost regret playing as soon as
i play it because i can't
like
i'm running through in my head all of
the words and that i want to use and
things i want to say
and i have to just no can't say that
can't say that i can't say that and i
have to be very careful and selective
you know if you think i'm i'm harsh in
the things that i say i don't there's
like 95 percent of it especially when it
comes to these parents and what they do
to their kids
95 of it has to be left on the mental
cutting room floor because i can't say
it out loud
uh but that is monstrous and this this
is a woman who should be in prison she
should have her kids taken away from her
um
locking your child in a home
for 18 months
i mean listen to what the girl said she
said oh it means i can go outside
this is the kind of thing that in any
other context
if you heard and we do hear about cases
of kids being locked in their home
by their crazy
uh abusive
barbaric parents
and in any other context when you hear
that
you think well this is this is a this
this is horrific abuse
these are kids that need to be taken out
of the home they need to be removed from
the home forcibly
they need to be saved from the clutches
of these barbarians
in any other context
except in covet somehow it's okay
i mean taking covet out of it for a
second
let's just imagine
that exact same kind of video
except it's uh it's the flu
the flu which as i've said a million
times
is a much greater threat
a more lethal threat to children like
that young girl there than covet is
and yet if covet never existed and you
heard of a parent who kept their child
locked in a home for 18 months for fear
of the flu
wouldn't even let them go play outside
with their friends
you would say that parent is crazy
this is not simply uh you know a
parenting choice a judgment call no
that's insane
and you are a danger to your child
what's no different here how could this
be any different this is worse
this is worse because because covet is
less of a threat to the kids
and somehow we just accept this and
meanwhile that
what makes all this all the more uh you
know just
an additional morbid irony here
is that
that mother
is uh extremely overweight
okay
so
she has her child locked in a home
really to protect herself
because she doesn't want the kid to
bring covey back to her
and so for her own sake to keep herself
safe she keeps the kid locked away and
yet she's that concerned about her
safety uh but and she's willing to
deprive her child of a childhood
take everything from she will take
everything from her daughter rather than
deprive herself of milkshakes and french
fries
she's so concerned about her health but
she's still gonna have the milkshakes
and french fries every day
okay you get a physique like that by by
eating fast food like every day i mean
you have to try
you have to try to put that much fat on
your body
not trying to be mean well i am trying
to be mean to this particular person
anyway because they deserve it
but yeah you got to try i mean you you
have to put in at least
no effort whatsoever when it comes to
your diet and fitness
and so she's putting in no effort
willing to sacrifice nothing for for
health
but to her daughter she says you got to
sacrifice everything
[Music]
repulsive horrific terrible
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content